هناك تعليقات لبوتين تعرفها
خلال مقابلة، وتعرف أنها تقول
إن مجموعة فاغنر غير
موجودة بالفعل، إنها موجودة ولكنها ليست موجودة بشكل قانوني،
لذا فهي غير موجودة حقًا، أعني
وربما هذا هو الهدف هو
الاستمرار فقط  لإرباك الناس وإبقائهم في حالة
تخمين ما إذا كان الأمر يتعلق بمكان وجود
يوجيني الذي تعرفه باجوسي أو تعرف
ما إذا كانت القوات
يتم تدريبها بالفعل، وما إذا كان
لديهم مستقبل مفيد لروسيا، أعني،
أليس هذا هو الحال؟  الهدف الذي
نسيته، كما تعلمون،
هناك الكثير من العبارات السخيفة
التي هي نوع من التوجيه
حول هذا الشخص يفقد المسار ولكن أعتقد أن
ما يحدث هو أننا نرى الكثير من
الدخان في المقدمة هنا، الناس ليسوا كذلك
أنت تعرف بالضبط ما
يحدث، والتصريحات السخيفة ولكن أعتقد أن
ما يخفيه هو الكثير من
التمركز في الغرف الخلفية داخل الكرملين،
لديك نخبة تحاول
معرفة حسنًا، أنت تعرف أين أتناسب
مع من أضعف اليوم ومن سيذهب  سيتم
إضعافي الأسبوع المقبل وكيف يمكنني
الاستفادة من ذلك وبوتين مدرج
في تلك الحسابات، وهو نفسه يقول
حسنًا، ما مدى قوة هذا الشخص في مواجهة
هذه المنظمة وما الذي يجب علي
فعله قبل كل شيء للبقاء في السلطة  لذلك
أعتقد أن ما يحدث خلف
الكواليس دائمًا ما يكون من الصعب جدًا معرفة
ما يحدث بدقة في
الكرملين لأنه يخضع لرقابة مشددة